- All right, well have you
been getting out on drives
still, like are you using
all those cars you own?
- Well you know what I'm doing?
I'm here in my garage right now.
This thing behind me
is called a 3D Printer.
We use it to make parts
when I work on cars.
But what we've been doing --
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, we've been making these.
We've been making these masks,
and we make them for free.
The machine runs 24 hours a day.
We've got a couple of them here
and we turn out these masks.
We just make this part.
This plastic part.
Another guy makes this part.
And you sort of put them on like this.
You know, like you would a
mask. And we give them free.
We just make them for free.
We just turn them out all day.
We give them to the fire department
and they give them to first responders.
So you feel like you're doing something.
- Yeah.
- You know, I always --
I always tell people,
"Maybe you've got old blankets.
Maybe you've got things you
can give to the Goodwill."
I mean, everybody can do something
to help out a little bit,
and that's kind of what we're doing.
I mean I enjoy working on my cars,
but this machine doesn't
(phone ringing)
make parts all the time
so what we do is we just for the last two
or three weeks we've had it running.
(phone ringing)
This is all the spare pieces here.
This is what they look like when they come
out of the printer.
(phone ringing)
- That's so cool.
- Yeah and we just,
we bang these out and it's really cool.
And we give them to first
responders and who else,
whoever wants them.
- That's really cool. And I
know you said it makes you feel
good or feel like you're
helping but you are helping.
That's a really incredibly cool thing.
You could be like you said
you could just be like a lot of Americans
just sitting at home
watching TV and eating.